former President George HW Bush will
spend Memorial Day in a main hospital
the spokesman says the 93 year old mr.
Bush was found to have low blood
pressure and fatigue one week after
traveling from his winter home in
Houston ship Reid is at Southern Maine
health care in Biddeford not far from
the Bush family home in Kennebunkport
chip good morning well good morning mr.
Bush is the oldest of the six living US
presidents and he has battled some
health issues in recent years his
spokesman said that when he was admitted
here yesterday he was awake alert and
not in any discomfort the day before he
was hospitalized with fatigue and low
blood pressure President George HW Bush
joined fellow veterans at a pancake
breakfast to Mark memorial day Brent
Scowcroft his former national security
adviser was also there just last week
hundreds of people waving American flags
welcomed mr. Bush back to Kennebunkport
I think it's important because he's had
at such a difficult year that he comes
back in a place that he's comfortable
with that he's happy with he has spent
nearly every summer in the quaint
southern Maine town where his family
owns a compound and on Sunday there were
plenty of well-wishers for the 41st
president after losing his wife and now
coming home and everyone's been so
excited to see him and support him in
April mr. Bush was hospitalized in Texas
for nearly two weeks battling an
infection he became ill the day after
the funeral of his wife Barbara the 93
year old also suffers from a form of
Parkinson's used as a wheelchair and has
had repeated bouts with pneumonia
mr. Bush was supposed to attend a
Memorial Day Parade in Kennebunkport
today unfortunately he won't be able to
make that he's expected to be here for a
few days and by the way you can see
Dorothy Walker Bush pavilion that's
named for George HW Bush's mother Fionna
he is a fighter and we are wishing him a
speedy recovery chip thank you